par une forme olympique ouais dites-moi
pierre j'ai lu dans la presse que vous
étiez pas bien c'était malade
oui j'ai lu aussi j'ai lu aussi je ne
savais pas et est alors oui les médecins
traitants merlen il ya aussi des
troubles rien donc je vais chez un
médecin avec leurs conneries tout ça je
l'aurais dit gens issus malade dit
qu'ils avaient jugé pas mais je les lui
alors il faut absolument trouver
j'ai remarqué pierre palmade à un
hors-jeu les gens meurent des personnes
mais là il y avait marqué gros soucis de
santé
alors j'ai fait les analyses ont conclu
une fortune et c'est le pire c'est que
ça s'est su et du coup ils ont marqué
après grosses inquiétudes autour de bien
pâles mal puisqu'on le voit partout dans
les hôpitaux on s'en sort plus
mais faut lire les journaux on apprend
plein de choses on apprend plein de
choses ça j'ai réappris j'avais acheté
une rolls par les journaux la nage et
free mais j'essaie le journal sur
l'avant de ma poule o et je peux dire
que ça le faisait à sa rivale aer et
pour les histoires d'amour des fois
c'est bien des fois non la dernière
c'était bien ce que j'étais kane et
filles superbes et cette année kane et
on sait pas sauf une fois sur une photo
bien ces tests avec un mec donc pistes
pour ériger une fois j'avais lu
formidable acteur il sait tout faire
les français l'aiment et alors là
j'étais vraiment content pour daniel
auteuil
voilà
inutile de vous dire que cet expert du
nouveau spectacle de pierre donc on va
en parler dans un instant qui sera à
partir du 17 décembre au palais des
congrès salle bordeaux puisque donc
comme on disait tout à l'heure voilà
vous allez au palais du congrès parce
que la salle s'appelle bordeaux bien sûr
ses co écrit avec un tas de gens qui ont
énormément de talent et à michel blanc
il ya jean loup dabadie ya gérard darmon
ya ramzy dehbia d'eric et ramzy
muriel robin françoise voilà alors les
quelques sketches bon on va pas les
raconter ce qu'elle s'assurera que
raconte pas la télé ça va se voir enfin
il échoit impossible en saas et j'étais
particulièrement sensible parce que j'ai
un truc simple et des questions cons on
en est aux gens s'ils préféraient hitler
ou staline leur père ou leur mère
alors là bon ça commence avec les
lentilles et les lunettes très simple
voilà effet après c'est quelqu'un qui se
posent des questions pas très qui pour
lui sont vitales comme si tu me fais
avoir des dents en bois ou une jambe en
mousse mais pour lui suggérer c'est très
vital et plus encore par il farrell
envoie bouler et puis ça l'énervé est-ce
que tu préfère avoir une tiare linda
vous préférez avoir une tête de veau ou
un bras de 9 m visé parce que la tête de
veau bon d'accord vous gardez votre voix
certains voir un jour vous vous dites
mon jour normalement de rater quand même
pas dire bonjour
fait plusieurs fois le tour est très
grand a posé la question à michel noir
parce que lui il mesure quand même
pratiquement d'asthme est donc peut-être
qu'avec alors est ce que il ya aussi une
truc line âge vous la jouer les
questions sur avis moi je dis est ce que
vous préférez répéter chaque fois que
vous essayez ou être suivie par 40
canard par exemple ces avis bien sûr
ajouter avez vu c'est pas d'la et 40
canard c'est la vie tout est argent vous
avez vu de 40 qatar qui vous suit 40
canard 40 canard corinne sonar